all right here's the first story we got
from timcast.com australia sends their
military to enforce coronavirus
lockdowns in sydney npr reports the
military's help is needed to enforce the
restrictions because a small minority of
people thought the rules didn't apply to
them new south wales police minister
david elliott told australia's channel 9
australian prime minister scott morrison
has come in for heavy criticism in
recent weeks over the slow pace of
vaccinations in australia where about 14
have been fully dosed one of the poorest
records among any member country of the
organization for economic cooperation
and development so when they say a small
minority thinks the rules don't apply to
them did they mean by that 86 percent
because that doesn't sound like a small
minority to me now here's the
fascinating part of course they're
bringing in the military
morrison said if you get vaccinated
there will be special rules that apply
to you why because if you're vaccinated
you present less of a public health risk
you are less likely to get the virus you
are less likely to transmit it the prime
minister told reporters on friday
according to the sydney morning herald
well now according to the new york times
the and the washington post and the
daily mail and many other outlets
you are not less likely to transmit it
so i i don't know that's what they said
i'm not going to say they're right i
don't know youtube's rules are all
they're all crazy i will point this out
though you may have noticed in the past
week there were crazy protests you see
these there's crazy protests all over
sydney thousands of people were in the
streets in sydney and like london
yeah um
this is not about a small minority of
people that are defying this is about
thousands of people in the streets chaos
erupts in sydney as anti-lockdown
protesters clash with police there was
another story that said basically the
same thing chaos in sydney because
regular people were going on with their
lives as though there was no lockdown
chaotic huh yeah people just continue to
do their thing how much so what did they
do
deploy the military
yeah i mean so first of all i think
there's a lot of competition in in this
race in these lanes but australia seems
to have had one of the craziest
reactions to coven 19 of any major state
i mean i don't i don't ever want to give
incorrect figures but the the day over
day rolling death average there is it's
below nine i know that it's at extremely
extraordinary way lower yeah it could it
could be that that's the most liberal
estimate i've ever heard sort of past
year the vaccine is available the thing
with covet 19 is that not everyone is at
equal risk from covet 19. i mean that
that's mundane as hell but it bears
repeating i mean tim you pointed this
out to me before the show i mean the
total number of people under 40 that
have died
from covid you would 9 000 or something
like that it's like it's like 9 700
something i don't have the full numbers
but it's yeah the nine thousands yeah
the the total number of individuals
under 18 at least in the usa because we
keep hearing about the children that
have died from or with covet 19 is under
600. it's 331 yeah that's a population
of 75 million so i mean the the question
with australia is have they gotten most
of their seniors and they're very
vulnerable people vaccinated i happen to
know they have i mean that's where they
targeted that first
chunk of vaccine that got up to around
15 percent of the population so the
question is can you keep healthy younger
people that are mostly at very low risk
of death frankly from covet 19 or even
hospitalization at home
for months and years at a time to
prevent
nine deaths a week or whatever i guess
max that number per day in a country the
size of california texas i would say no
i mean that seems utterly bizarre in
terms of how we look at liberty there's
a well do they have any there a lot of
people are making the joke that's like a
former penal colony and they're okay
well you know
perhaps i guess you know i was thinking
about this and maybe there is something
to that we
as americans
fought for our independence to win it
people in australia it was part of you
know i don't know the full history of
australia but you know penal conley i
don't know their full the the numbers
for australia i can only really speak to
the us
but i will say that there was there was
this viral video that was uh um
crazy and hilarious i suppose it's a
news report of australia where they're
like one person has been infected
we'll be locking down for the next month
and it's like wait what it's like
wow people have gone gone really over
the top with this stuff i tell you i see
some of these stories and i'm like if
there was anything if i was if i was
trying to advise any of these people to
like discourage vaccination i keep doing
what you're doing this is this is a
great no they're trying to get people to
get the vaccine but they're just doing
basically the opposite you think when
you have 14 of your population getting
vaccinated sending in the military is
going to make them think you have the
best their best interest at heart ah the
opposite because th you go this route
there's no turning back
now you have dedicated yourself to
authoritarianism you have sacrificed
your trust and credibility where can you
go after that
well i mean you can go some ugly places
but i actually this is to me by far the
most disturbing thing about covet 19. i
mean the the things that the citizenry
has allowed to be kind of placed on the
table
um
so even before the vaccination i mean in
in the usa something like 2.8 to 3.1
million people die every year
i mean that's that's damned close to ten
thousand a day it's eight or nine
thousand so even at the peak of covet 19
i had no objection at that time to
wearing a mask i actually got one that
works which most people didn't
but you're not seeing a devastating
world ending plague like even at the
peak of covet 19 there's no evidence
really if you look at like the west the
western european studies the major
pieces that were actually published in
journals that lockdown's worked better
than sort of well-done npi you know stay
home if you feel sick quarantine the
sick clean your body that kind of thing
but now with the vaccine out and in most
of these countries including australia
the truly vulnerable vaccinated you're
seeing these utterly bizarre moves like
you're what you described as a factual
situation there was one infection and
correct me if i'm wrong but that wasn't
a death that wasn't i don't know the
whole news story they were talking about
just like some viral video where they
mentioned a guy someone got sick and i
think he was hospitalized but they're
not dead and they're not going to be and
so they locked down 900
000 people that's new south wales i mean
that's a that's a region that's roughly
comparable to one of the dakotas it's a
huge state decent number of people in it
um
i think if this is possible in reaction
to that level of risk
like
one let's say death means 900 000
incarcerations for three months it would
be very
very difficult for these western
societies to do anything functional
going forward not even the stereotypical
war with china but what are we going to
do about climate change like this this
stuff's not off the table like i said i
foresee climate lockdowns being a very
real possibility they've already talked
about masks next flu season and at some
point people are just going to have to
say no i'm going to vote for the
conservative party or even even the
libertarians or whatever is necessary to
crazy stuff
whatever is necessary to kind of get
this
you should not stop living your life
because someone else might die that way
lies a society with no cars you know so
on down the line some people do think
this is the climate lockdown we saw
very early on after a couple weeks the
lockdown new york times posted that
story saying the earth is healing
and people started talking about a bunch
of articles emerged about pollution and
everything clearing up and then a lot of
people said they're probably exploiting
the crisis because they have the climate
change agenda
but then you know i i wonder
first you know i'll say this i don't
trust the powerful political
establishment and elite they they claim
climate change is a disaster but they
buy beachfront property and things like
that so
part of me wonders though we talked
about this the other night with
windshield the windshield phenomenon
have you ever heard of that no no i
haven't frankly people have started to
notice that when they drive their cars
there's less insects than there used to
be and so it's called the windshield
phenomenon and they've done studies
where they found like an 80 reduction in
uh over over from 2017 to 2021 i think
that's what those are the dates
they found a reduction of 80 percent in
insect populations hitting windshields
and a lot of people think that what you
can get grants for in science by the way
is absolutely amazing bro i mean that
that's got to be at least a million
dollar project but sorry well sure sure
a waste of money uh and and not not a
waste of waste of money in terms of
doing the study though but you know they
wasted money when they did the study
that's right for sure how much money do
you need to drive the car back and forth
for four years a million dollars because
we're going to hire someone to drive
we're going to do this driving in
barbados
home of the next american you know
etymological association conference
right right yeah yeah but but isn't
there something that's scary to that and
uh you know that's what i'm worried
about what if
what if there is an ecological collapse
and that's why they're actually locking
everything down i mean would we want to
just
you know eat and fart ourselves to death
like like yeast in a bottle or would we
need some collective action to stave
something off or or the worst are there
ideologues who believe a doomsday
scenario who have seized the reigns of
power and are imposing their cult like
ideology over everybody else
well that's a that's a fascinating uh
bit of a bit of a leading question
there's something we're both skeptical
about you know leadership around the
world but i in reality so there are a
couple different elements to this first
of all i am not a conspiracy theorist
because i think most people are stupid i
mean we're both from chicago i believe
both from that south side area oh yeah
where where where um i was born in the
bridgeport area of the city oh okay i
moved uh north to wicker park
pre-gentrification i went to st mary's
uh oh wow yeah midway yeah yeah yeah and
i lived in uh bridgeport for a little
bit but
by comiskey right or by u.s cellular
field yeah that's right down there
that's all that that's white sox country
that's all right i have family and um
that whole like chatham
uh bronzeville that whole area sort of
black and irish and uh south side of
chicago that's right now i like i said i
personally claimed the north side i went
to i was in wicker i said i was like a
little kid i moved to i still have a
house in east aurora like the
traditional sort of latino and eastern
european area that city so another
blue-collar area right nearby an hour
away i know but and that's and and and
what were you saying you think people
are dumb yeah well that's that's that's
hey what are you saying about chicago
no that but that's the point though i
mean like even watching people i knew in
high school try to sell coke in little
italy or east aurora or something i mean
the percentage of those guys that went
to jail is like 65. i don't think that
there are actually functional
behind-the-scenes cabals where you have
one arab guy one nigerian guy one french
guy two americans and a brit that are
secretly trying to control the economy
of the world or something like that i
think i do think you have groups i mean
many of the things that people say in
sort of conspiratorial conversations
like skull and bones at yale or
bilderberg group actually exist you have
groups of rich people that clash with
one another and pursue different agendas
just like you have groups of upper
middle class people that do this or
media individuals but i do think like
first there was a weird
sort of climate porn that you saw in the
mainstream media for a while where you'd
see these headlines like whales have
been spotted in such and such a canal
and it's like that's because there
aren't any goddamn people like you yeah
excuse the language but they've they're
taking all the the ships out of the
normal shipping lanes people are on
lockdown that's not a positive of the
the best of these articles either from
covid or within the couple of years
before was the guardian why genghis khan
was good for the environment
because he killed so many people you see
that the smoke from the cook fire
stopped the planet cold are there some
other people that would like to make
those claims about
um i think i think so
well i think that today i don't think
there's a conscious attempt to usher in
a climate lockdown because of covid but
last sentence kind of getting to the
point here on my end i think that
the bigger issue is that the people that
are running a lot of american discourse
have the same solutions to everything
this is is so if you notice the climate
solutions like we need to pursue a more
socialist generous policy of xyz are the
same as the kovitz solutions and the
same as the proposed solutions to our
race crisis so i i don't think the issue
is so much
what the key that opens the door is it's
kind of what comes through like all of
these things are being used by people
that want the same agenda to a certain
extent
yeah it's a it's a standalone complex we
often say it's it's not a conspiracy
it's a bunch of people of similar
ideology working in a similar direction
because they believe similar things
but when you look at the pareto
distribution of you know basically
almost everything in existence you get
the extremes at the very top and at the
very bottom but these extreme
wealth of file
powerful people maybe this is see i
don't have any data to back this up
except that
you know you look at sociologically
there are times when the very very few
will will coagulate at the top and i
wonder if there are a small group of
people that have been organizing this
since i mean if you look at the way the
federal reserve was built by like eight
guys yeah jackal island that was crazy
creepy story
true but i think the issue of the
creature from jekyll island right i
think the issue with that though is that
well at the simplest level in political
science about half of the rich disagree
with the other half i mean that's that's
why there's this extraordinary kind of
back and forth of like well you're
funded by the koch brothers well you're
funded by george soros and the sciences
i mean you have the chinese billionaires
that unexpectedly are kind of coming in
often on the right side of things
politically yeah i mean on the other
hand you have the the moon men these
tech bros that are currently flying
around in space so i i don't think
there's
one unified position that people are
advancing across say great wealth to try
to move
the world forward i think that there are
some positions that are more influential
than others
because one group of sort of coastal
upper middle class urban big city mostly
leftists happens to control the media
social media and academia in the usa and
britain in particular so there are ideas
you see more often than you see other
ideas and i think that that is the the
climate panic is one of those but i
don't think in practice uh governor
desantis or somebody is necessarily
going to back that actually happening or
the billionaires in that state are going
to you're familiar with the journal
lists
you ever hear of those not journalists
journal like
journal
dash list it was a list it was it was a
web list of journalists that all
communicate with each other oh yeah yeah
this is this is this is a good example
of
i guess i don't know it borders on
conspiracy in a sense in that they would
all share stories and then agree on them
because they were all in the same chat
and then all of these outlets would
publish the same stories well to clarify
i don't think conspiracies don't exist
actually to talk to kind of the audience
for a second if you don't think there
are wealthy powerful people
behind the scenes that sometimes collab
together to do things that would get you
arrested you're a fool
i mean like even at my little level like
i'm pretty i'm a member like the lower
upper class and i'm often contacted by
friends from the u of i law for example
or
you know
freedom fest which i just attended great
event but reasonable pretty high level
stuff media figures do you want to work
on this um let's keep this low-key for
now we're gonna we're gonna trip them
from behind with this one and i would
only imagine what prince harry's inbox
looks like so of course they're
conspiracies in that sense the question
i guess really is just
when it crosses the line to the crazy
scenarios a lot of the left and the hard
right seem to believe in so like for
example my email list right now is i
think 8 000 people nothing crazy but 8
000 most of them are journalists of some
kind they're mostly on the center right
i'm pretty sure i could create a story
if i happen to find out some piece of
information about a crooked politician
the
the only reason that's annoying when you
look at the journal lists or a lot of
these i mean there are a whole like jobs
that are left is still up on google
where they advertise all these
left-leaning activist jobs and it's one
network of people many of whom don't
admit they're left-leaning activists so
the issue with that i think is the
pretense of neutrality right so if
there's anybody from say cnn or npr on
on the message list or that that's very
ethically problematic
i think both you and i would say like
i'm heterodox maybe center center right
politically i think the government's a
bunch of scumbags like i have the set
group of opinions pretty open about them
if you say i'm a neutral reporter for
nbc
and you are taking talking points from
you know a junior operative at the dnc
that you're sleeping with who's the
person ahead of you on the journal list
oh my no but i mean are you talking
about a real person there
no of course not a gentleman would not
say such a thing but i mean like if you
and that actually is i have someone in
mind they don't work at nbc and it's not
pretty i know you're talking about
maybe but anyway but anyway like the
the point of all this is that if you go
on the air and you're saying this bs
this goes for the right as well like all
these guys talking about chastity until
marriage is critically important and
lock the door javier you know like if
you're doing that there's a significant
ethical issue with that i think that's
really the only point there are many
conspiracies behind the scenes
journalists have opinions and you know i
i used to think that we would try to
have journalists keep their opinions to
themselves so they could just do the job
and and not cause strife
but i i think that that era is is long
since past you know because the
difference in opinions now is is
fundamental world view where someone's
opinion is literally them saying i
support the constitution and someone
else's opinion saying i oppose it and
i'm like well hold on there a minute
like we've got a very very distinct
difference of world view on this thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 p.m where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you